all right look I realized I'm not the
first one to point this out but I really
just cannot get past how oddly toned
deaf it is for Netflix to do squid games
IRL like I'm sure there is some
entertainment to be had from Netflix's
upcoming squid Game reality game show
there have certainly been game shows and
reality shows with stupider Concepts but
just how do you go from producing one of
the most critically beloved TV shows of
the Year about the evils of capitalist
exploitation class solidarity Etc and
then be like okay right uh anyways let's
do it for real this time well okay
there's no dying but basically for real
the entire trailer for this thing just
smacks of did you watch your own show
but I guess it worked for Mr Beast so
who am I the judge